Aww yeah! Today, we are learning English
with Beauty and the Beast.
You are going to watch some scenes from the movie
alongside an interview with actress Emma Watson.
You're going to greatly improve
your British pronunciation,
learn tons of vocabulary grammar and so much more.
If you're new here, this is how the lesson
will work:
you'll watch some clips with subtitles
then we'll teach you all of the most
important vocabulary, pronunciation,
and cultural context, before you test
everything you learn by watching it a
final time without subtitles and
answering some quiz questions.
Let's get started!
Wouldn't you like to be able to understand the jokes
when you watch your favorite TV series
and movies in English?
Well, our Fluent with Friends course
can help you a lot.
In this 48-week course that follows along
with the first two seasons of Friends,
we will help you to understand every single
joke, plus you get 20+ page PDF Power Lessons,
vocabulary memorization software,
access to our Fluency Circle Global Community,
and so much more.
What are you waiting for?
You can try it for FREE with our 3-part masterclass.
All you have to do is click up here,
or down in description below
to learn more and sign up.
Every week, we make lessons like this
to help you understand natives
without getting lost,
without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles.
Just like this learner from Brazil, who
says that he can understand what he couldn't before.
And you can improve your
English comprehension too.
All you have to do is hit that Subscribe button
and the bell down below,
so you don't miss any of our new lessons.
Hey after you finish this lesson
be sure to check out this funny lesson
that we made with an interview of Emma Watson
on The Ellen Show.
Alright! I hope you had as much fun with
that lesson as I did!
And don't stop the learning now.
Be sure to improve your British vocabulary
and pronunciation in this lesson with Emma Watson,
or check out all of our lessons with Disney movies
in this playlist.
Now, it's time to go beyond the classroom,
and LIVE your English.
Aww yeah!